n'a effectivement j'ai tout à fait
d'accord à ce que nadie et puis
effectivement moi ce que je trouve
aberrant donc je suis pas d'accord je
pense qu'il fallait la coupe au montage
mais ce que toi aberrant c'est de voir
qu'aujourd'hui un buzz négatif sort de
chiffres de si jolies choses derrière
c'est à dire que maintenant tout le
monde se l'arrachent
c'est un objet de curiosité haïti
devient le voeu pour l'interviewer c'est
devenu une très grande chance
on savait pas qui c'était du tout et
maintenant c'est mariah carey c'est la
grande chanteuse et ou alors que sa part
ken dam d'un buzz négatif d'un tweet
très discutable c'est ça qui est perdu
notre société c'est pour ça que je pense
que tf1 aurait dû utiliser le buzz
négatif pour le transformer en buzz
positif c'est-à-dire au lieu de virer
mesnel d'un coup utiliser mesnel
justement pour faire passer des messages
plus grand plus fort plus positif mais
plutôt montrer où c'est difficile
effectivement moi je me mets à la place
de tf1 lorsqu'on se dit effectivement
les terroristes et leurs gouvernants
gouvernement on comprend que ça choque
qu'on a une réaction impulsive mais tf1
aurait pu mieux faire et utiliser
effectivement mais elle est bien gardé
et fait rêver en faire un marketing plus
positif
sauf que là on discuta fois vu dans ses
yeux qui va donner la parole oui mais de
quoi reparler en fait j'étais en train
de dire que nous c'est facile de
raisonner comme ça va quoi fois en dix
ans la sur le fait qu'ils auraient dû
faire six auraient dû faire ça et sur
quoi ces prestations sur ma maman
souvenez vous d'une espèce d'entonnoir
aubry n'est assez facile de rater les
chirac
voilà alors vous vous êtes vous d'accord
et florent pagny ou pas non ce qu'on
s'était bien instinctif blanc pas dit
d'accord âgées pas d'accord à sa grâce
et partage ses 48 52
c'est me suis-je bourricot